おはようございます肇社長です
めっちゃもの買ったんよ download 4つ礼拝ました分何かと言いますと
うわぁいやいやいや
ヤダー
ん
[音楽]
巨大空母です何かいろんな生き物いるんですけども結局へ足の中に巨大なとこが一番
怖いなと思いましてこちらを大量に買わせていただきましたまーなんかすげー顧客空か
ボニーてんな
赤い目が2つ付いております
いやだね俺久保がいい家だべちっちゃい子もだったりつい助けるこんなて足のサイズや
バクですかどこか寿司腕とかホラーやばいよこれ美味処さんあのこれじゃやばいなこれ
あってるかわかんないけど今リーン a
ああ
箱のサイズ感ですよででかすぎて声はこれはもう画面いっぱいクマで追われちゃいまし
たよこれ
こんな巨大な蜘蛛今回大量に買いましたこれだけにて足伸ばした方がいいと思うんで
ます全部て休んで申します
あああああ烏来ああああ
[音楽]
ああ
買いすぎたん
はいというわけである保谷いっぱい学問になってしまいました
さすがに入りすぎたこれは何ヒラー大大ファン10匹ぐらいますね本当に
気持ち良いですこういうわけでこの大量のかも使って何をしようかと言います今は世の
部屋でちょうどねぺる男がいるんですよ
[音楽]
結構眠り深いんで今のうちに何とかしてこの雲全部運び込んで出てるからの周りを全部
この超巨大空母にしてあげたいこれいいか ddr 2対応の組に絡まれてる価値を
再現して寝て起きたらめちゃくちゃん雲に囲まれているときに行ってみたいと思います
どうデー
ています
[音楽]
着地でもういない口ます
を
[音楽]
持った
ん
茶番だった
4日
ううーー do
ていたぐうっ
えっ
ん
予備は買っちゃおう
九頭見てですよあっはぁ硬派
あああああああ目辛い谷へ
雲ドッキリでしたーー
どうすかっと
縮小
絶対一家殺してやるからな
[音楽]